The new season of Game of Thrones is fast approaching.
But in order to look at where they might be heading we have to go back
Back to the cover of the first book. We have an image of a sword, but what can we learn from it?
Answers are never easy with George RR Martin. He's always asking us to look under the surface.
Let's enhance. There's someone's reflection in the sword. It appears to be one of the lesser known characters
Crispy Bill
Interesting. What's this in the reflection of his eye?
I thought so. It's a 1950s recording of Elvis Presley doing the hound dog
Hound dog
He's telling us the hound wears a dog helmet. Well, we already knew that
Let's go deeper
Okay, so we set a board of Catan for us
I'm quite good at this what cards do we have? Two wood and two for Rick?
I have enough to build two roads. That puts me in front to take the longest road car
What's this? The longest toad card? "You'll find my secrets in the mouth of the toad"
"Sure, come on in." Let's go inside this toads mouth, but
That would be too easy. Wouldn't it?
So I'm gonna go up his anus, right
By my calculations it should take us three weeks to reach the frogs mouth if we take this route
I'm not really sure where we are, lord. It's a sort of mucky cabin dripping with feces
We have enough rations for two days. So we should be able to live off the land or frog, so to speak
And in case we get lost I have my mate Baz to guide us through
Now the video feed isn't great but we are up a frog's anus so bear with me
Let's take stock of our supplies. We've got
a paper clip
There's some sunflower seeds, a couple of empty batteries and an .... So what use is all this?
I suppose we could...
Not sure what we can do with this though
Wait a minute
The seeds
What's inscribed on the seed, it's some sort of rune. It's the 2014 Olympics logo. No..
It's Bart Simpson and Sideshow Bob.
It's Little Jim.
Go away Little Jim, what was I doing? Stop touching me? What was that?
What's going on out there?
There's a new longest toad in town.
Long live the long toad!
Has anyone seen any  (...bugs?)
Long live the longest toad!
I was told there would be bugs.